bonjour bonhomme et carbone merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france on l'a
vu on vient de le voir des restrictions
sont de retour en france en martinique
et puis notamment à nancy est le
président du conseil scientifique
préconise hier de reprendre des
précautions justement pour lutter contre
le virus à l'extérieur est ce qu'il faut
le retour du masque à l'extérieur
renault mégane non je ne pense pas qu'il
faille se prononcer de la sorte
effectivement aujourd'hui les
contaminations progresse de façon
exponentielle
il y un risque majeur que dans quelques
jours on puisse assister à une quatrième
vague hospitalière
tout doit être fait pour éviter que les
contaminations s'aggrave davantage et
donc effectivement dans l'état actuel de
la vaccination qui est encore
insuffisante pour prévenir
l'augmentation des hospitalisations
il faut malheureusement mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
restriction on voit bien que la
propagation du virus est très variable
aujourd'hui sur le territoire
il est essentiellement localisés dans
les départements le long du littoral
méditerranéen ou atlantic 2 car
effectivement ce sont des lieux de
vacances où les gens se mélangent le
virus circule essentiellement parmi les
personnes jeunes se sont donc dans ces
départements qu'il faut probablement
mettre en place des restrictions
alors évidemment le masque à l'extérieur
à peu d'intérêt épidémiologique
le virus se propage essentiellement
lorsque les personnes ne peuvent pas
garder une certaine distanciation
physique donc notamment dans les rues où
finalement ils font la queue ils sont à
l'arrêt discutent entre eux et donc dans
ces lieux effectivement il est peut-être
intéressant de mettre en place le masque
un espace ouvert
al'inverse marcher dans une rue on est
sûr d'être à distance de toute personne
de plus de 2 m
l'intérêt est beaucoup plus faible vous
parliez de restriction dans les zones
les plus touchées par l'épidémie vous
parliez de la zone méditerranéenne pour
l'instant effectivement on est en
période de vacances estivales les
français
bouger un petit peu dans tous les
départements du pays est ce que les
restrictions devraient pas être plutôt
national que local
non je crois pas il faut que
effectivement les mesures soient adaptés
à la situation épidémiologique locale il
n'y a pas de raison dans un département
où pour le moment il n'y a aucune menace
réelle que on met en place des mesures
de restriction importante à nouveau
aujourd'hui la population est
essentiellement dans les lieux de
vacances
c'est là où les personnes sortent se
brasse et donc on des interactions
sociales importantes c'est là qu'il faut
mettre des mesures de restriction mais
il est vrai que à la fin des vacances
un peu comme l'année passée lorsque
toutes ces populations de vacanciers
reviendra lorsque cette population
reviendra vers les grandes
agglomérations notamment la région
parisienne il puisse y avoir ce moment
là évidemment une augmentation des
contaminations dans ces villes et qu'il
faille alors mettre en place des mesures
de restriction mais on espère évidemment
que d'ici là la vaccination permettra
bien sûr de protéger les populations de
tout risque de maladie grave c'est
pourquoi évidemment l'objectif cet été
est de vacciner le plus grand nombre le
plus rapidement possible alors justement
bono meilleure balle en parlant de
vaccination le pass sanitaire a été voté
hier à l'assemblée
est ce que c'est un passage obligé
selon vous pour davantage inciter les
français à les faire vacciner
oui je crois que effectivement c'est un
passage nécessaire car c'est une course
de vitesse entre une épidémie qui
progresse de façon exponentielle en
termes de contamination et une
vaccination qu'il faut atteindre la plus
large possible pour protéger contre les
formes graves voire l'étal de la maladie
et donc effectivement plus on met des
moyens pour qu'on va dire accélérer la
vaccination et mieux c'est je crois que
le pass vaccinale
le pass sanitaire pardon a eu un double
intérêt tout d'abord bien sûr de pousser
à la vaccination le plus largement
possible mais aussi de garantir des
espaces de vie collectifs où finalement
il n'y a pas de danger ou lorsqu on y va
en y accédant avec ce pass est bien on
sait que on va pas en sortir contaminés
et c'est un point important bien sûr
pour permettre à ses activités
économiques et sociales de persister
donc le pass sanitaire est bien le moyen
vers la liberté
pour éviter tout risque de devoir
refermer les commerces les lieux
culturels et les lieux de loisirs alors
une partie du débat hier à l'assemblée
vous a concerné conservez-vous qui
travaillaient à l'hôpital puisque les
patients non urgents et les visiteurs
devront présenter un pass sanitaires
pour pouvoir entrer à l'hôpital visiter
leurs proches
consultez également ou visiter dans
l'est dans les ehpad c'est une bonne
chose selon vous alors juste je me
permets de vous corriger l'impression
que en fait c'est plutôt l'inversé
c'est-à-dire un amendement a été voté
permettant de ne pas exiger aux patients
et aux familles c'était voté une
première fois hier et revotés très tard
dans la nuit
je sais bien voilà les députés sont
revenus justement sur cet amendement
d'accord très bien très bien alors je
dirais j'étais un tout petit peu on va
dire on va dire entre deux concernant
cette ces mesures donc je crois autant
pour les familles effectivement il
paraît indispensable de présenter un
pass sanitaires car rendre obligatoire
la vaccination pour les soignants dans
les hôpitaux et les ehpad est une chose
extrêmement importante mais laisser un
côté un canal largement ouvert qui
permettrait à des membres de famille
d'entrer dans ces établissements non
vacciné sans test et d'apporter le virus
serait totalement contradictoire
on sait qu'au cours de la troisième
vague les contamination nosocomiale à
l'hôpital et on n'est pas de son fait à
la fois par le personnel soignant mais
aussi par les familles d'ailleurs le
fait de ne pas rendre le pass and i ter
obligatoire pour les familles pourraient
entraîner un certain nombre de services
hospitaliers prenant en charge les
patients fragiles sous chimiothérapie
immunodéprimés à interdire carrément des
visites ce qui aurait été
malheureusement aussi très péjoratif
pour les patients humaine
al'inverse concernant les patients là je
serai un peu plus critique
je crois que la notion d'urgence pour un
patient est plus difficile à définir
il ya bien sûr les urgences médicales
les urgences vitales que l'on peut
définir en fonction d'un certain nombre
de critères objectifs
al'inverse à côté il ya l'urgence
ressentie par le patient est donc
effectivement il sera difficile d'exiger
des conditions pour pouvoir prendre en
charge
relativement rapidement certains
patients qui auraient un ressenti
d'urgence alors même que leur pathologie
ne le serait pas donc je crois que
malheureusement on doit faire le maximum
possible en fait pour respecter l'esprit
de ce pass annie terre c'est à dire on
va dire faire vacciner le plus grand
nombre possible le plus rapidement
possible et on voit que en pratique il
peut y avoir quelques paramètres
critiques ap
merci mme obou à bruno megaman d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes le chef du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris merci beaucoup